Korea's literally out here living in 2040 because.
What do you mean? PDRN hyaluronic cream,
aka salmon spur moisturizer,
the luxury niacinamide pigmentation dark spot corrector.
This stuff feels like literal luxury skin food.
It just glides on and look at that glass skin.
And finish.
It gives you juicy oil cleanser for your first step in your routine.
And if you're not oil cleansing,
you absolutely need to be,
because this is what's gonna dig up all the dirt.
SPF Makeup, whatever gunk is actually on your face
so that you can follow with their viral Heart Leaf foaming cleanser
with BHA and quercetinol.
I cannot tell you how incredible this foaming cleanser is.
It's not super harsh where it's gonna strip your skin.
gonna give back that luscious cleansing layer that we want to achieve.
After you've done the heavy duty with the oil cleanser
and then the hyaluronic soothing toner,
once you finish cleansing,
you need to be going in with a toner.
But not just any toner. Preferably one with hyaluronic.
And this one has the hyaluronic.
And you guys do not be using pads and stripping your skin
when you're putting toner on.
You want to be pressing the toner in
so that you're actually absorbing the ingredients.
After a fresh clean,
screenshot this order of steps that you can get foundation allocation.
And if you want plump, buoyant glass skin,
then you need to make sure that you're using the right ingredients
in The correct order. And what's further is
a new is actually giving away a free full size product right now
with this entire Ultimate Bundle.
And this bundle is normally worth over like a hundred some dollars,
so the fact that it's already this cheap,
plus you're getting a free product right now
because the Spring Glow Up sale is insane.
So if you want that plump Radiant PDRN moisturizer glow,
I would run to get the bundle while it's on sale
and you get the freebie.